hey guys welcome to biology professor
today I'm going to be summarizing some
news articles about how red pandas are
two species not one I've seen this
research been summarized in a few
different publications now but I'm
mainly going off of one that I read in
Newsweek the original research was
published and in the journal called
scientific excuse me science advances
and so what did they do to determine
that red pandas are made up of two
species instead of just one well we've
got a ton a team of Chinese researchers
they use whole genome sequencing so that
means that they extracted the DNA from
cells from 65 different red pandas from
different populations across the red
panda range they were mainly looking at
Y chromosome DNA and mitochondrial DNA
that's the DNA that we inherit from our
father and mother respectively so they
looked at seven separate populations and
determined that there were two separate
species represented there that separated
some time around 220,000 years ago so
we've got the Himalayan red panda and
the Chinese red panda and they do have
distinct ranges and so you might be
asking was this surprising and the
answer is not really
it had kind of already been expected for
a while they were already considered two
different subspecies and they also
differ in appearance for example the
Chinese red panda has like a rudder face
and has more distinct bands on its tail
but now we finally have the genetic
analysis to back it up to show us that
these two different subspecies are
actually two different species and so
you might be asking well how did they
form into two species well like I said
it happened about 220,000 years ago and
the two separate species kind of went
their own ways when they were separated
by a river so this is a form of
allopatric speciation if you are
interested in learning more about
allopatric speciation versus sympatric
speciation you can check out my video on
those topics but basically allopatric
speciation speciation is when you have
two different species that are
geographically
separated in some way either by a river
as in the case of these pandas or
perhaps there is you know deforestation
that separates them into two different
forested areas with an unfortunate area
between them or like a gorge forms for
example there are two different species
of I think it's squirrel one that lives
on the north side of the Grand Canyon
when it lives on the south side of the
Grand Canyon and they were separated by
the river forming that Canyon you know
millions of years ago and eventually did
did form into separate species
so that's allopatric speciation
sympatric speciation is when you have
species that diverged despite being in
the same location so again you can check
out my video on that topic if you're
interested in learning more about it so
what else so these researchers learn
about the red pandas first you need to
know what a population bottleneck is a
population bottleneck is when you have a
really sharp reduction in population
size over a really short period of time
this can be caused by a variety of
things for example if a if an infectious
disease wipes through a species and
kills 80% of the individuals of those
species then that would be a population
bottleneck because when 20 percent left
something like like drought or famine or
a new predator coming into an area or
climate change basically anything that
has a sudden impact on a species
resulting in having its numbers sharply
decrease that's a population bottleneck
and it's important because when you have
a population bottleneck it typically
reduces the genetic variety of the
species by a large degree so if we go
back to my previous example if you had
80 percent of the individuals of a
species die because of infectious
disease the 20 percent that are
remaining will probably have less
genetic diversity so less variety in the
types of genes and the types of genetic
mutations that they have which means
that that species might not be a stable
any
and so what they learned is that the
Himalayan red pandas have experienced
three bottlenecks and only a small
expansion afterwards meaning that this
species has lower numbers and lowered
genetic diversity whereas the Chinese
red pandas as the other species has
experienced only two population
bottlenecks and a larger population
expansion so it has higher genetic
variety and the larger population size
so of the two of them the Himalayan red
pandas would be the ones that are most
at risk and so why is all this research
important well the red pandas are
already endangered even if they were
just one species that one species has
low enough numbers that it's already
considered endangered this is due to
habitat loss poaching as their numbers
have dwindled there's been a lot of
inbreeding and so you have a situation
where you've got only a few thousand red
pandas left and losing more every day
and so this research now that we can
realize that there are actually two
separate species those two different
species can have individual conservation
plans developed for them so they can
have the individual protection plans and
conservation biologists can work with
zoos with governments with locals to
make sure that a different the two
different species of red panda are both
being protected and it will also prevent
crossbreeding in zoos so you won't have
a Himalayan red panda and a Chinese red
panda being you know being mates in a
zoo situation because now zoo keepers
will realize that they are separate
species so that's it for today what do
you guys think of the red pandas they're
they're cute little animals their faces
are a little rodent II for me but
otherwise they're really pretty really
pretty red fur and so what do you think
about the fact that they are two
different species and what this means
for conservation efforts let me know in
the comments bye